Kenneth and Armando you two are the
first male same-sex couple in the 90-day
franchise what are your thoughts on this
oh we're excited about it a little
nervous what are you most nervous about
personally yeah just not knowing what to
expect I'm recently coming out so I just
you know I'm putting it out to the world
is a big step for me I never dreamed I
would move to another country but I'm
here in Mexico to be with the love of my
life do you think he'll approve of us I
think he would approve of us I'm just
worried about our safety people in
Mexico are still homophobic well Armando
knowing that your family does not
approve of your sexuality what made you
say okay yes I'm gonna do this show it
was more I obviously want to show our
love our story and I also wanted to kind
of push myself push my boundaries and
and I was afraid to come out to my
family and obviously I was afraid to
come out or for the world to you know
know that I'm gay because I you know I
was just afraid all around but in the
way it was like it was something to kind
of push me
um push myself and in the end and I you
know be going through a lot of things in
my life when you go through the hardest
moment in the end it's like you end up
having like a great outcome so I was
just hoping for that and I am hoping for
that still like with this airing but in
the end it's a positive outcome and that
I don't regret me we rip the band-aid
off yeah real quick gotta - just do it
jump out there and then I mean there's a
lot of people that are probably gonna
watch that can relate to your story so
you may help them when it comes to
healing in some parts of their lives
yeah a lot of it a lot of it was that to
meet you again being through struggles
and coming
not accepting myself I also wanted to be
someone that helped um others in the
world and you know kids might you know
with the things I felt when I was a kid
and even you know not just not knowing
where I was in my life and so I be you
know people will connect to that and
kind of understand it and others will be
able to be inspired I guess and their
true selves yeah it's true that you know
to show P people so she kids you know
that they're it does always get better
they're struggling and you know people
can have great relationships with the
same sex you know black people when
they're younger and I felt that way when
I was at teams with it there's no way
you know you can have a normal life it
seems like everybody else but you really
can and it's gotten a lot better
obviously over the years such a since I
was young but that was the main thing to
is just show people that two men can
love each other and have a great life
together
let's talk about noir love for a second
there's a 26 year age got in between you
two which is mind-blowing because
Kenneth 57 looks great on you I will say
that you look up what I say is like when
we met we didn't have an agenda meaning
that we were looking for each other we
weren't looking for a relationship we
didn't need on a dating app you know we
just became friends
so that thought was never there for us
um it was not - a year - we actually met
and then it went from there but we were
already so close as friends and got to
know each other and our sense of humors
and things like that just meshed and so
initially like Armando brought up he was
like you know you're at the type of guy
I would like go or something like that
and I was surprised because of the age
difference
what about our age difference says I
don't care and once he didn't care it's
been the best you know the best
relationship I ever had Wow and the
thing is meaning you know we didn't meet
each other like oh how old are you um by
the time I found out as a you know we
had already been talking a lot we had
already laughed a lot so like I had
gotten to know him as a person and
fallen for I mean at that time we were
friends
I really liked his picture as you can
attest he looks younger or he looks
young in his pictures so again it wasn't
like I was seeing like an old guy like
that so you know that made a difference
by the time I found out at a gym and I'm
an old soul so it was kind of like me
also balance yeah
Kenneth what do you want fans to know
about your relationship if you can just
tell them one thing before they watch
the series what would it be to UM give
our story a chance especially to the
people that might not believe in
same-sex relationships to give ours a
chance to watch our story watch it
unfold and they might just see a love
story and they might change their mind
and their heart you're gonna see some
ups and downs with us you're gonna see
some differences because of our age and
some differences because of our culture
and some differences in our parenting
styles so you will see all that it's not
all roses lots of emotions difficulty
yeah we have a lot we're we're very
emotional people if I can tell and it
does come out it seems that actually
doing this show has really shown me I
didn't realize
was this emotional until it came to our
relations should have so it doesn't
matter what age you're at I really
believe this then you know you can find
love and you can find something inside
of yourself that you never thought you
have this show has been very positive
for me in that aspect that I've really
found a lot of out about myself that I
didn't even know and our story is
hopefully uplifting for the most part
and helps I hope it helps a lot of young
people out there that might be
struggling and um to be able to accept
themselves love themselves and know that
it it's better at the end of the tunnel
[Music]